oh doctor actually ended up doing these
kind of function experiments
and what happened is that
the I mean if you go back just
historically and I'll make this very
brave
when I was a kid I think this is a long
story but when I was seven years old uh
president is an hour made what is today
probably the greatest speech in America
most important speech American history
where he warned Americans against the
obliteration of democracy if we allow
the military-industrial complex uh to
continue to expand to emerge and and
dominate you know democracy
my uncle took over his president three
days later
I was at that inauguration
he spends his three years fighting the
military industrial complex dies my
father runs five years later
um running against the military
industrial complex the Vietnam War
he dies during that campaign and then in
and you see the expansion with Nixon
coming in and you know the military
getting more and contractors taking more
and more control of American democracy
in 89
the Communism collapsed and we're all
told we're going to get a beast of it
and
and you know that the money that went
into that
billion dollar stealth bomber that
cannot fly in a ray in the rain okay
that that billion dollars is now going
to go to schools and hospitals and Roads
and you know and health care and
improving quality of life and we're all
saying this is going to be great we're
gonna pound the weapons into plowshares
if there were people in our
you know in we're like listening to that
and saying that's coming out at Beast
evidence coming out of my pocket
oh 93
or years later we have the first
terrorist attack and there's a
screeching hole to all that money that
was headed towards civilians is now
it goes into terrorism Islamic terrorism
and it gives us justification to be at
basis and you know 670 bases and
countries across the world and all of
these you know this Global hegemony
but Islamic terrorism has a problem
because it's hard to justify these huge
allocations of our GNP
to a harm or potential or risk that
kills fewer people every year Americans
every year than lightning strikes and
when the World Trade Center attack
occurred in 2001
three weeks later there was an Anthrax
attack
and that and our country you know first
Bush and then Obama
said that declared officially official
documents that bio security is now the
spirit tip of American foreign policy
and germs are much more appealing than
Islamic terrorism because terms can get
into everybody's home and they can kill
you
and people have a natural repugnance of
germs and it's easy to exploit that fear
to get them to give up their
constitutional rights and to turn this
into a National Security State
ruled by the people that is now or
warned us against
Oh I thought she was part of that you
know that Anthrax attack was used as a
justification to to invade Iraq it
turned out we found out later that the
anthrax came from one of three U.S
military Labs somebody in the U.S
military that was Associated and it had
nothing to do with Saddam
a military began and people who were
involved in BIO Warfare began funneling
huge amounts of money into bio Warfare
it's illegal in 72 we signed the treaty
we closed all of our BioWare Warfare
Labs Nixon signed the treaty saying
we're never going to do it again we're
not never we're not going to create them
we're not going to study them we're not
going to
I use them and we're not going to to
store them
bio weapons so the military wanted to do
bio weapons research
but it was scared to because of the
legal violations and so they started
taking this money
and funneling it to ni agents
specifically Tony valgie so
beginning in 2001 immediately after
those attacks he began receiving 1.6
billion dollars a year or to do
essentially bio weapons research there's
a loophole in the bio weapons treaty
that says you the you can do bioweapons
research as long as it's what they call
dual use oh as long as you can say
you're developing vaccines
you can develop bio weapons
and
Tony fauci had a personal stake in this
it gave him a payoff which is they gave
him
and the Pentagon gave him that money
he also got a 68 pay raise
that is attached to his bio weapons
research Tony fauci did a is I has paid
official in the U.S government he gets
434 thousand dollars a year the
president that's only four hundred
thousand that was the next biggest so
and why does he get that he gets almost
70 percent of it comes from his military
work
oh he is taught he has a 6.1 billion
dollar budget which is money just he
just gives away two scientists to do you
know to do basically drug development
and then he has an additional 1.6
billion so it's uh it's about 7.7
billion altogether
it comes from the military and that he
had to justify by doing these gain of
function studies and you know at first
it was completely unregulated
he really and I talked in the book about
how he manipulated the regulation and
got controls of the committee that we're
supposed to be overseeing him by putting
his grantees on those committees
and he began and then in a bunch of the
bugs escaped in 2014 and 300 scientists
signed a letter to Obama saying you got
to stop essentially Tony fauci from
making any more of these bugs
and that year he began
transferring his studies to the Wuhan
lab the Chinese were welcoming them and
the Chinese were and one live is run by
the Chinese military
you cannot work in that lab without some
association with the Chinese military
and the Chinese military
are very Frank what they're doing is a
weapons development
and so you had all this this group of
characters very you know interesting and
uh
um people like Ralph Eric from the
University of North Carolina and Peter
dazak who had their own self-interest at
and made excuses to themselves that they
were
you know doing the I mean listen
Tony fauci is saying it out of the
corner of his mouth he's saying we're
doing this in order to develop vaccines
it's countermeasured
the people who know most about this area
like Mark lipsich of Harvard and
um and Richard
a bunch of others hey there's not a
single development that has come out of
gain of function research that has
helped in any pandemic including this
one is worthless research
but Tony fauci himself was funding Ralph
Barrick
to create
um these legation processes where you
not only are developing these pandemic
superbugs you're also developing
methodologies for hiding the fact that
they were bioengineered oh the nosium
edits and ocm edits oh and the
interesting thing about that is how do
you justify them why in the world why is
that
a benefit to Public Health right under
one baby and fauci was funding that
right and you you would and you would in
fact want the exact opposite because you
would want the ability to at least know
when something you had done exactly
caused a harm
[Music]